el programa nuclear que irán tiene sus
orígenes en la guerra fría a finales de
los años 50 el país era liderado por el
char reza pahleví con estrecho aliado de
occidente
la cercanía entre la nación persa y
washington llevó a las potencias
occidentales a colaborar con el
desarrollo de tecnología nuclear con
fines pacíficos pero la luna de miel
finalizaría en 1979
la revolución islámica rompió por
completo la relación entre irán y
occidente y aunque los planes nucleares
conjuntos se interrumpieron la
infraestructura y el conocimiento ya
estaban en territorio iraní los años
siguientes fueron de secretismo durante
los años 2000 las alarmas saltaron por
cuenta de información de inteligencia
estadounidense e israelí sobre
instalaciones de enriquecimiento de
uranio y agua pesada los siguientes años
serían aún más tensos stage white disc
en estados como irán y sus aliados
terroristas constituyen un eje del mal
que se arma para amenazar la paz del
mundo
la nación iraní producirá por sí misma
el 20 por ciento del uranio enriquecido
y todo lo que necesite
las sanciones económicas por parte de
eeuu a irán y la llegada al poder de un
gobierno menos radical hizo que teherán
se sentará a la mesa de negociación y
años más tarde logrará esta histórica
imagen
[Música]
por primera vez la nación persa se
comprometía a permitir inspecciones en
sus instalaciones nucleares a cambio de
que eeuu levantará las sanciones una
solución que dejaría a todos los
conformes
llega a la presidencia de eeuu de donald
trump volvería a cambiar la situación de
tribunales anunció que eeuu se retirará
del acuerdo nuclear con irán nuclear día
tras el anuncio en 2018 del mandatario
irán retomó el enriquecimiento de uranio
y las sanciones de washington se
reactivar durante la presidencia de
tromba las tensiones crecieron y los
choques fueron más frecuentes con la
llegada de joe vayan a la casa blanca la
esperanza de un nuevo acuerdo vuelve a
vislumbrarse en el horizonte